Carlotta est désemparé deux jours après
son arrivée au chemin roxam cette jeune
femme angolaise est de retour dans une
station-service de platsburg avec sa
fille de 6 ans et son conjoint
ici qu'un bus venant de New York avait
déposé cette famille avant qu'un taxi ne
les emmène au chemin Roxane
mais c'était trop tard ce passage venait
de fermer à peine quelques heures plus
tôt
impossible maintenant pour la plupart de
ces migrants de rester au Canada en
vertu de la nouvelle entente sur les
tiers pays sur qui inclut désormais ces
passages irréguliers à la frontière
c'est dans ces bâtiments américains
juste devant la frontière que patiente
finalement les migrants qui n'ont pas pu
rester au Canada et qui sont maintenant
livrés eux-mêmes certains n'ont pas
d'argent n'ont aucun contact aux
États-Unis on ne parle pas anglais mais
les douaniers américains leur demandent
d'appeler un taxi pour venir les
chercher bonsoir
les gouvernements canadiens et
américains ont échoué et non pas pensé
aux conséquences humanitaires c'est une
crise il n'y a aucun plan sur cet élu
américain et déjà
Carlotta est donc revenu à platsburg
tout comme son compagnon d'infortune un
congolais encore sous le choc je suis
pas incriminel je suis je n'ai rien fait
de mal pour un jour et vous expulser
quelqu'un comme ça
c'est pas normal ils songent maintenant
aller à Burlington puis apporte l'un
dans le main une ville connue pour aider
les migrants
pour nous tous un autre taxi et donc
venu les chercher pour les conduire
cette fois-ci vers un lieu qu'ils
espèrent plus accueillants en
s'installant dans la voiture Brialy
pense à ses six enfants restés au Congo
et qu'il voulait faire venir au Canada
mais je vais leur dire la vérité là où
j'espérais trouver mieux on en a pas on
n'a pas voulu m'accepter je veux voir ce
que la minute me réserve si je trouve
mieux aux États-Unis
ici romain Suez Radio-Canada plateburg
dans l'État de New York